hancock has announced that these
additional measures will now apply to
those two new areas that you mentioned
greater manchester and lancashire county
council they join a host of other areas
including bolton actually that matt
hancock singled out
as an area where these additional
measures have actually been working well
to control the spread of the delta
variant the
origin of course was india for that
particular type and it's something that
the government has been worried about as
we talk about
relaxing more opening things up in the
next couple of weeks the spread of this
variant and increasing numbers of cases
so what does this mean for people living
in those areas well
it means that they will be asked to
minimize travel in and out of where they
live and work
now that applies as i said to bolton a
number of other areas at the moment
also people are being asked to socialize
outside if possible not
inside of course the legislation has
been relaxed the restrictions have been
relaxed so people can meet now indoors
but people in those particular areas are
being advised that to try and control
the spread they should be meeting
outside where possible
to keep two meters apart now the
government will give some extra money
there will be
surge testing there'll be testing inside
schools the health secretary said
and of course he urged people to
continue getting their vaccinations that
of course is the way that the spread of
this variant
and covid in general is going to be
controlled so the fact that the
government has moved two
new pretty big areas into these
additional measures just shows you that
they really are trying to do everything
they possibly can
to avoid the spread of this variant but
what it will do is prompt some questions
some difficult questions for ministers
about local lockdown something that
they've always said they want to avoid
they want to have everybody in the
country coming out of restrictions at
the same time
well clearly now that doesn't
necessarily apply in these areas
all right kate many thanks indeed for
now we can in fact uh bring you uh what
the health secretary matt hancock had to
say about this
extra testing today working with
local authorities we are providing a
strengthened package of support
based on what's working in bolton to
help
greater manchester and lancashire tackle
the rise in the delta variant that we're
seeing there
this includes rapid response teams
putting in
extra testing military support
and supervised in-school testing i want
to encourage
everyone in manchester and lancashire
to get the tests on offer we know that
this
approach can work we've seen it work in
south london
and in bolton in stopping
a rise in the number of cases this is
the
next stage of tackling the pandemic in
manchester and in lancashire and of
course
it's vital that people in these areas as
everywhere else
come forward and get the jab as soon as
they're eligible because that is our way
out of this pandemic together